were you married do they have a single
want to be married
selection she's on her phone a lot I use
Facebook YouTube snapchat Instagram
scrolling emailing I come in there at 11
o'clock at night he's on the phone with
some girl what's her name I don't know
oh you know my phone doesn't have any
apps on it cuz I have a flip phone
it's a Kaia that's how it is yeah he's
on the phone with Sakaya and she wants
everyone in the shot with her but I do
like funny pieces see I don't really
know a lot about taxes other than it
comes over April I've done my packs on
my own a couple times I feel like it
just makes your brain hurt I got
somebody else to do my taxes it's like
it's math class times 50 call me very
interesting interesting good luck with
that let's start with your personal info
have children dependents own a home you
don't know my birthday I didn't know
everything this is June and July gets
mixed up did you live in another state
in 2015 no state of confusion
did he pay for most of his living
expenses yes how many months - Daniel
live with you in 2015 every last one of
us will you legally blind December 31st
no ok what is that little question mark
means thank you for contacting turbo tax
my name is Aaron may I have your first
name please hi this is Sheldon Fisher
and I would like to know how can I find
my refund information right here is the
refund amount
that number will either increase or
decrease depending on what you have on
your w-2 oh how cool
thank you okay how would you like to
enter your w-2 oh you could take a
picture of it instead of filling in all
the all the numbers and everything yeah
Oh fancy oh so easy alright what you
getting back 4,000 I had that much money
to myself
goodbye motorcycle I actually would buy
a motorcycle
thanks to Disneyland Disneyworld go on a
cruise go to Paris
you guys didn't earn anything that's my
money our money our money see were
family I'm proud of him he did better
than what I thought seeing how much my
mom pays in taxes definitely makes me
think more about how I spend her money
thank you